[Musique]
m
vous venez juste au finish une
tamponnais order of the group
il était important de gagner
pour déjà pour le club ivoirien 1 avec
vraiment besoin et pour nous les joueurs
surtout pour nos familles nos parents et
nos amis il est important de gagner ce
match là et surtout il ya eu la manière
et c'est très important pour la suite
avec au retour et pourrait que ce qui
est beaucoup
le pc est à la fonction aux députés au
ghsr
papa et
j'ose espérer qu'on n'est pas encore à
notre maximum mais il ya encore pas mal
de choses à corriger améliorée mais j'ai
beaucoup aimé l'état d'esprit encore des
gars ont la volonté de faire des efforts
ensemble lorsque je suis passé dans le
vestiaire j'ai fait le tour des joueurs
ils m'ont dit coach on s'est régalé et
malgré l'enjeu malgré la pression malgré
le fait de jouer contre les fennecs de
l'algérie ils ont pris du plaisir et
fois de plus beau pour un coach lorsque
les joueurs suivent les instructions et
prennent du plaisir donc vraiment bravo
à eux
à
tlj de votre prochain adversaire
ils ont pleins d'étoilés si elles n'ont
pas besoin
de pression c'est
l'egypte on a le temps pour se préparer
et a porté sur mac mon fils mathis
finalement c'est quoi c'est dit dans les
vestiaires après trois étapes
voilà c'est dit